hey guys at seven you may know it it's a  new addition to my wall and that is my  template for the BTA calendar this is to  help me stay on track of my BTA numbers  as well as my daily habits when i'm  looking for our 10 people to help me  beta test this this is the october  calendar and i want your feedback and I  want your advice on how to make it  better and hopefully it motivates you  and inspires you to stay on top of not  just a BTW a number but the daily habits  that you need to go through to be  successful on the regular basis so i'm  going to do was the first 10 people to  leave a comment on this video I'm gonna  personally connect with and send you a  free copy of this and I want your  feedback what you think how to make it  better and hopefully make the November  one even better so let me know first 10  comments and go